[Music]
philadelphia is the city in the eye of
this election storm right now
a democrat stronghold accused without
evidence of cheating by the president
and they are defiant
two more questions in the building where
they continue to count vote by vote
officials are not holding back so can i
just ask you again to address
uh and respond to the president's
statement
no i think what the president needs to
do is frankly put his big boy pants on
he needs to acknowledge the fact that he
lost and he needs to congratulate the
winner
just as jimmy carter did just as george
h.w bush did
and frankly just as al gore did and stop
this and let us move forward
as a country and that's my feeling i
doubt to listen to me but
that's it as they have before they again
took the media for a tour of the count
past the protests outside
this is where the last few remaining
thousand ballots for this city
are being tallied desks with glass tops
those are the extractors they tore the
envelopes
and people pulled them open the space
here is for monitors to observe at any
time
they can't go closer but the counts are
streamed live for anyone to watch
how's the count going great outside the
counting hall al schmidt is the
republican commissioner for the city
and is appalled by the president's
accusations okay well that's good
but there are monitors in there right i
mean you're every day all day
yeah all day yeah independent wellnesses
uh from both parties no the democratic
party and republican party
uh have both been in there the trump
campaign and the biden campaign
have both been in there every day all
day we're there all day
so we would know so what do the people
behind the votes make of all this
over the two-week run-up to the chaos
we've crisscrossed the state
a four hour drive to the west in the
rust belt is john's town
where we met trump supporter eric cabler
last week
how's things i think donald did a very
good job
from philadelphia today we caught up
with him but i think
the level heads will prevail here as as
we move forward
and you know i think the vote was the
vote and
again we move on and hopefully we move
on
we all agree both sides of the aisle
agree that
we need unity going forward and that's
this is probably the first step to it so
hopefully we move forward
of course among the president's base of
support there are those who believe him
and will stand with him and that makes
this a moment of continued uncertainty